el nuevo líder de el partido conservador
y Por ende Primer Ministro será
anunciado el próximo viernes 28 de
octubre tres días antes de que el
gobierno el Primer Ministro el ministro
de finanzas tenga que presentar y
defender en el parlamento el plan
financiero para salvar la economía de la
crisis así lo ha confirmado el jefe del
poderoso comité del partido conservador
comité
1922 que sigue ahora tendrán que
presentarse candidatos para reemplazar
al Isra se espera que estos candidatos
se anuncien el próximo lunes y luego
abría la participación la elección de
los miembros del partido unas 200.000
personas que podrán votar de manera
Online para elegir al nuevo líder pero
hasta el momento no se conocen todos los
detalles el hecho es que Boris Johnson
el ex Primer Ministro hasta hace pocos
meses Está liderando las encuestas y se
habla de la restauración de como Primer
Ministro
bueno los partidos de oposición también
piden elecciones generales es necesario
este escenario en este momento
la gente Quienes no hacen parte del
partido conservador creen que ha llegado
el momento de que se les dé nuevamente
la opción de ser consultados sobre Qué
tipo de gobierno Qué partido quieren
votar en esta ocasión la última elección
general fue en diciembre de 2019 El jefe
del partido laborista el partido más
grande en oposición kirstarmer ha dicho
que el país lleva 12 años de fracaso y
que el Reino Unido se merece tener otra
tipo de opciones que se debe acabar esa
puerta giratoria del caos mientras que
la ministra principal escocesa Nicolás
torjon con quien mantiene una disputa
legal con Londres para realizar un
segundo referéndum para independizarse
del Reino Unido ha dicho que las
elecciones generales son un imperativo
democrático Así que esta es la situación
que se vive en este momento pero los
conservadores saben que si abren la
puerta para unas elecciones generales
que deben ser de maneras votadas y
aprobadas en el parlamento británico
estarían abriendo la puerta para que
después de 12 años puedan entregar el
poder al partido laborista que según las
últimas encuestas encabezaría y
arrasaría en las elecciones generales